bonsoir avoue henri mennecier merci
d'être avec nous pour décrypter donc
l'issue de ces élections fédérales en
allemagne avec le spd qui arrive en tête
devant la cd ou et le parti vert un mot
peut-être sur le parti d'anna-lena
bareback qui effectue une percée on peut
voir les choses ainsi
contrairement notamment à l'afd qui
avait marqué le coup on s'en souvient en
le parti à cette avancée de gagner deux
prix un peu plus de 5,5 points mais ce
qui est important celui de tourner ce
soir autour de 14% bon comme on l'a dit
les résultats définitifs qui sont pas
encore par convenir nasa notamment des
résultats du vote par correspondance
mais le vert or autour de 14% sur
beaucoup moins que ce qu'ils attendaient
et surtout les verts ne pourront pas
propre à diriger le futur gouvernement
et malgré tout c'est un grand succès
pour ceux constatés car il sera
inévitablement membres de la future
coalition et c'est un parti absolument
incontournable maintenant comme ça a été
souhaité auparavant et il faut voir
quelle sera les accords seront conclus
l'an passé soit avec les chrétiens
démocrates soit avec les et les sociaux
démocrates
la situation est compliquée dans la
mesure où qu ce sera sur toute
vraisemblance un gouvernement à trois
parties et donc il faut qu'il y ait une
entente non seulement avec les verts
mais également avec les numéros des sacs
aux bidons des négociations assez
difficile on peut imaginer aussi
que le spd tout proche des verts en tout
cas sur certains points de programme
notamment l'augmentation du salaire
minimum ou la hausse de la fiscalité
pour les hauts revenus ça peut être à
l'avantagé du spd ça dans la coalition
plus l'entente entre le spd et les verts
ne devraient pas poser beaucoup de
problèmes ce que les verts attendent une
styliste un engagement plus fort en
faveur de la butte de la politique
climatique et de la lutte pour
l'environnement la rente est possible le
problème c'est que s p des plus verts
n'ont pas ensemble majorité absolue il
faut un troisième partenaire et
ameublement se coller le croiser par
partenaires ce peut-être soit les
libéraux soit le parti de la gauche
extrême avec les libéraux il colle à des
problèmes et des saignements les
difficultés sous les questions au fils
cadet n'égale et les questions les
questions budgétaires mais également sur
la politique de la route de la politique
d'environnement l'anssi la négociation
sp thé vert et fdp échoué il y aurait
encore une possibilité pour le spd et
les verts de se lier à tous partis
allemands qu'on appelle dinning la
gauche extrême qui est la suite dans
cette partie communiste de l'allemagne
de l'est de l'allemagne de l'est alors
contre ce la difficulté qu'il ya pour
une telle coalition spd verts et dingle
gauche extrême c'est surtout le
dézingueur regard des accords assez
fondamentale sur la politique extérieure
un peu sur union européenne mais surtout
sur l'existence même de l'otan sur les
exportations d'armes de l'allemagne est
sous les engagements militaires de
l'allemagne et en dehors de
l'europe ou rendu emplois hors d'europe
donc là il se pourrait tout réductrice
et ses raisons pour laquelle il faut pas
eu au cas où ces négociations spd verts
échoué avec le numéro ou bien avec la
gauche l'extrême c'est souvent là que le
cdo pourrait peut-être reprendre le
flambeau et essayer de former un
gouvernement chrétien démocrate et vert
écologistes et le numéro donc voyez que
ne sera pas ce ne seront pas une
promenade de santé
et elle promet promettent d'être dur et
les durées lors tout à l'heure à la
télévision les trois principaux partis
se sont plus ou moins engagés ou en plus
ou moins promis que les négociations
devraient être terminés en gros avant
noël
peut-être sur la neige des déceptions
pour l'afd mais tout de même le parti
d'extrême droite allemand sans crevin
confirme son ancrage au sein du goût des
stades
oui je profite des résultats et a des
bons résultats de sept de ces élections
il a évité le recul est à peu près de la
bouée de deux points laisserait plus
générales vous pas oubliée que
indépendamment sélection fédérale il y
avait aujourd'hui aussi deux élections
régionales a perdu par la ville de
berlin étant considérée comme une région
et dans le land de mecklembourg
fortement commune années antérieures de
lens qui le plus au nord-est de
l'allemagne près de là et la pologne et
là aussi elle a épuisé à a fortement
reculé surtout en pole en mettant
boubers année où le parti a perdu près
de 8 8% les gens profit des hommes du
parc de la mairie mise en mots par
porsche pour souligner que les effets de
la vidéo était extrêmement importante
non seulement au niveau fédéral
légalement au niveau régional le
mecklembourg-poméranie antérieure était
l'élu lot de madame merkel elle sa
circonscription dans le bâtiment elle
était président de la cds ou deux
secondes etc or aujourd'hui le parti
s'est complètement effondré sous son dvd
qui vous le pouvoir et les aider ou
s'effondre à quelque 14% seulement à
être plus mauvais résultat depuis 1900 à
une salle dise où on peut dire que le
bilan électoral de la ceni où ce soir
est véritablement catastrophique alors
les allemands évidemment doivent
trépigner parce que la question c'est de
savoir quand même qui va succéder
quel est le candidat finalement des
partis qui va succéder à angela merkel
olaf schulze
il est plutôt bien positionné un
bien pas bien c'est bien sûr je pense
qu'il va sortir hanter votre tout petit
peu plus d'an j'ai dis parce que des
résultats définitifs ne sont pas ne sont
pas publiés normalement il sauve vers
minuit les résultats mais qu'on appelle
définitivement encore provisoire
résultats vraiments définitifs seront
publiés dans le prendre le semaine enfin
les résultats
dames et dire qu'ils m'en sortir vers
peut-être une heure du matin
le donnerons quand même éducation très
très très précises bon en attendant ses
résultats mais comme je l'expliqué le
système politique allemand vue que les
élections fédérales ou dénis pas
tellement un chancelier et on élit des
parties et c'est ensuite aux partis
politiques de décider quel sera le gain
sera lui chancelier c'est ce qui est en
train de se produire ce déni d'ailleurs
ce soit dans les débats elle était
maternisé nos certes monsieur chose a de
bonnes chances d'être considéré comme le
candidat e de candidats leur série
préférée par les allemands mais encore
faut-il que les négociations avec ses
deux futurs partenaires c'est à dire les
verts et surtout soit les libéraux ou
bien eu la gauche est sain encore
faut-il que ces négociations puissent
aboutir je le dis si jamais il ne
pouvait pas me dire eh bien on
repasserait lourd passé le le jure
passerelle du côté des chrétiens
démocrates juste un mot ce rôle le vote
par correspondance on en parlait tout à
l'heure avec un léger ce sommet qui suit
pour nous ces élections à berlin
l'impact du vote par correspondance est
ce qui peut avoir un impact important
sur les résultats qui sont annoncés
actuellement on sait que les écarts sont
très serrés
nous on pense mais on n'a pas dû
voulait vraiment certifié par différence
avec la force ne voit pas correspondance
est très importants d'allemagne donc
j'ai pas du chiffre exact mais on disait
entendu dire que à peu près la moitié
des électeurs allemands en fait ces
années un vote par correspondance
c'est dû en partie à la crise est due en
partie à la crise la clé senneterre et
on pense que comme ce vote par
correspondance a eu lieu surtout la
période que le säntis se développer un
mouvement afin de m'aider que ce vote
pourrait être plutôt favorables ou sp
disney au parti social démocrate un
monsieur aulas hausse plutôt qu'à la cdo
dont c'est pour ça que on pense que
normalement les cas entre eux le spd et
la cdu ou ces sources il devrait devrait
s'agrandir au profit du spd pendant
celui merci beaucoup à vous henry
minutes et je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur honoraire à la sorbonne
spécialiste de l'allemagne